Oh
I think we should still somewhat
cultivate the image how in us so that
after all the learning and listening
whatsoever you still have to cast it
aside a little bit be playful and be
childlike sometimes here for 19 sunset
place the region site there was an
existing brick building a brick house
now we decided to keep the house because
the owner the lady her house grew up in
that area in any case a house is so well
though so we want to keep some little
history that we have in that area so
that was that was why we did it the way
we did what we did was we we had a sort
of a house was in her house
conservatives we just built this
concrete shell and covered the existing
house so this additional space
requirements just extended radially from
the center so what has happened is that
when we covered existing houses this
concrete show it has created a lot of
sort of the branded spaces around the
whole house some of them have rendered
spaces some of them are actually used as
bathrooms and many sama lamaa actually
just caught yet extensions in the
libraries in whatsoever so besides
catering to the additional space
reconsider the owners needed we also
actually shelter a large part of their
the habitable space from the Sun and
rain I think when they first saw the
rendering it went to fearful over with
it but eventually when we actually cast
it a concrete and when they actually
struck off the formwork and they saw the
dirty and craggy concrete so they
panicked a little bit so were they they
say look at it and said well you know is
this really what you want I say yeah is
this really nice as a yeah is gorgeous
and in any case I told them the house is
supposed to look dirty dirty and you
know I mean so it's a bit more rustic
looking
but it is supposed to be listing it's
supposed to be home as long as you can
actually make it your own and you're
comfortable with it and then it becomes
a house it becomes a home so what is the
house I am no I to me it's just shelter
and so as long as you're comfortable and
you feel that is you and I think that to
me will have service purposely and I'll
be quite happy living in a space like
that
you